Guys welcome back, and thank you for joining me today on the King of Random
Today I am super excited to show you about this really cool project about a year ago
I was contacted by Devin Supertramp who had this amazing video idea to do Mario Kart in real life
He wanted my help building Mario Kart shells to the proportionate size, but he didn't just want them as static props.
He wanted them to be able to drive around and run into the karts just like they do in the game
So here is one of the shells these things were a blast to make this is made of fiberglass and then painted to look like
The shells in the game as cool as the shell is just for decoration it wasn't enough
I needed to make it so we could drive around.
The purpose of the video today is to show you how I turn these shells into moving homing shells just like in the game
and then to show you what they can do
Now I didn't just want these shells to be able to move I wanted them to
Haul and so I needed a car that had some good power behind it so I decided to use this car from
Traxxas this thing is a beast under the right conditions it can drive up to 60 miles an hour check this out.
Alright, We're now out in a parking lot. We've got our car set up
It's hooked to the remote control, and we're ready to go. I wanted to show you why it is I wanted to use these cars
Doughnuts
So fast
I love it.
Okay now it's time to turn this car into a drivable
Shell come look at the car body
And how it's attached and we'll show you how to switch it out for the shell the whole body of the car is just attached
with these four anchor points
These four points that were holding the car body on are the same points
We're gonna use to attach the shell to attach the shell to the car body the first thing I did was mark four little spots
Of paint one on each of these support posts on the car
So it left four little spots on the bottom of the shell which I then drilled out
After you've drilled a hole in the shell comes the tricky part
You need to line the holes up in the shell with the posts on the car
And then attach it using these pins from the inside of the shell since a lot of this has to be done by touch
it's good to memorize ahead of time the
Orientation of the holes and the posts you can see that these two posts in the back
Have holes running forward and backward these two posts in the front have the holes running left to right
With the body taken off of the car you can sort of see all of the inner workings
You can see the drive shaft the motor that controls the car and the slot for the battery
The cars came with these little rings to help increase the tension of the suspension which is something
I want to do because of the weight of the shell
Three
Sometimes it is a blessing to have very skinny forearms
There's four
All right our shell RC car is ready to go. Let's open it up and see what she can do all right?
We're back out in our driving area. Let's see what this thing can do with the shell attached
So I have my phone now taped on to the back bumper of the car
And it has a GPS based speedometer on it, and so we're gonna track just how fast I can get this card going
I'm not actually 100% sure how accurate the app is we're gonna see what results we get from it anyway
All right according to my app the maximum speed this car hit was 30 miles an hour that is 30 miles an hour on
A remote-controlled car how awesome is that?
All right
So these things are so fun to drive around you could probably tell that
Maneuvering at high speeds didn't work very well the car has a tendency to tip over, at slow speeds
You've got great control and on straightaways you have crazy speed
I hope it's showing up really well in camera just how fast these things are driving there
You have it guys these things are a blast to drive around and if you want to see more footage of them in use go
Check out Devin Supertramp Svidler. He drives them around on a real-life Mario Kart course in the future
I'm going to show you all of the steps that I took to build these shells so that you can make them yourself
I really hope that you guys enjoyed seeing these shells in action as much as I enjoyed building them and showing them to you
Thank you for joining us for this project today, and we'll see you in the next one. Talk to you then
Well let's try that again but random happens
Hey guys back for just a second debts are a few questions. I've seen floating around
Where did I go and who is Nate well first of all I'm still here
I'm just not in the videos right now and secondly Nate is my new guy in training
He's gonna keep all the projects and experiments coming your way, so give him a high five to show your support
We'll see in the next video